pour le top 14 du post je vous demande
d'accueillir bernard laporte jeu
l'équipe de france pour nansen c'est
quand on y est t'as vu comment tu prends
m mais regardez non regardez comment il
prend le ballon bernard laporte
on voit que c'est pas comme nous
regardez regardez cette classe regardez
le caresse non mais sans rire qui le
caressent regarde regarde et regarde
c'est normal c'est la délicatesse une
bagarre si tu fais bien tu fais bien tu
fais bien la faute soit un peu plus loin
a suivi on essaye c'est une tenue de
quelle année c'est vrai mais ouais c'est
le président de la fédération concept
tournoi début saison passée reste qu'on
pouvait faire une touche est ce que si
on l'avait cyril parce qu'on peut
arriver à faire une touche et prépare
toi maxime je pense ça y est les voix
des mots bernard
c'est vraiment un amour d'être là je
voulais dire désires tu seras juste
bienbienbien métaux la balade chez toi
le patron et j'oserais dire tu seras
avec moi l'année prochaine dans balances
ton post les blessures voilà comment
c'est vrai aussi je voulais vous faire
cette annonce bien sûr il sera avec moi
dans balances ton poste l'année
prochaine bernard laporte le jeudi soir
balances ton post bien sûr continue est
donc très très très heureux tu sais que
je t'aime vraiment énormément
ça aussi ça c'est un mec exceptionnel et
j'ai vu t'as pris du galon et non plus à
international télévision et la classe du
mec je lui demande de venir faire un
truc le top 14 une connerie hier bernard
c'est pour ça que je t'aime bernard fau
ce mot c'est pour ça que nous t'aimons
mais non monsieur sûreté exceptionnelles
et on était vraiment d'été voisin
pendant des années on a les vandales et
jetez la poubelle ensemble ont rigolé
comme des fous lalala lalala bon tu me
violence et j'image que tu veux le faire
si c'est vrai je suis venu mais je sais
pas ce qui se passe là je veux dire ma
déco 14
cécile avec un plaisir sait même pas
pourquoi tu es sans appel top 14 je
venais chez top 14 parce que c'est quand
on sait le championnat de première
division en australie il est venu pour
faire ça
ce mec génial ah oui je suis désolé et
été battu qu'en fait m'a dit fais moi
juste premier lancement était juste là
pour lancer la séquence du top 14
l'ific alors vas-y ben voilà dans les
vestiaires ah vous le savez j'adore les
affaires et j'adore comme client c'est
donc tout naturellement que j'ai regardé
à faire faire des choses lui qui aime
bien qu'on sur france 2 et j'ai remarqué
que pierre-jean chalencon il est devenu
rader c'est un peu comme la pince dans à
prendre ou à laisser
le gave plus dans les doses hey pour moi
ça mérite tout simplement un gros
plaquage travail on t'aime et je
voudrais dire bernard laporte président
de la fédération française de rugby et
vice-président de la fédération for
international c'est un taulier et il
sera avec moi dans btp l'alefpa déplacer
je perds c'est aussi bon allez on
regarde pas les regarder c'était
d'affaires conclut mr simon bernard
lapeyre qu'on peut dire encore
[Applaudissements]
on a eu il ya quelques temps rappelle
produits en parfaite état mais bon c'est
un très joli meubles il est très beau
oui mal et ça c'est à ce que c'est vous
parce que chez moi parce que si nous on
ça un euro pardon président de la fédé
je suis excusé par bernard la fédération
et à revenir le président la fédération
internationale qui vient de mineurs
autour du rugby dans le monde
il vient pour faire plaisir que ça pour
rigoler je les adore j'ai même pas
regarder l'image d'un du coup c'est jean
pierre ferland sur l'action qui était
qui était maquetter euros les chéris
vous savez on est très méfiant avec les
technologies les machines un peu comme
cette dame dans l'émission cliquer sur
canal d'ailleurs sur un gros bisou à
mouloud mouloud voilà la classe aussi
voilà maintenant il est en phase sur
canal qu'est ce qu'il a fait hier dans
l'après midi je reçois un sms de mouloud
j'espère que tu va cartonner avec à
prendre ou à laisser et on t'aime voilà
c'est la classe merci mon boulot tout
d'abord regardé c'était donc lhi que ça
très drôle
les masques c'est pénible
est ce que vous faites confiance à
l'application qui vont mettre en place à
du tout envie j'aime pas les algorithmes
un les machines de n'iront jamais
peut-être voilà les alliés
la bateau n'était pas bien elle n'a pas
tort merci bas vous vous rejoignez sur
cette année bah oui j'ai un gorille
cette attaque et c'est pas le juste
milieu
merci ça que vous allez faire combien de
bonnes émissions pour savoir jusqu'où
génial quand
je vous le dis moi je vous regarde
s'ouvrit des fdf et c'est franchement
c'est un petit peu l'écho comme comme
quand je faisais de la télé chez moi
pendant le confinement ce soir chez mama
c'est un petit peu idf1 et je suis tombé
sur un animateur qui ne connaît pas trop
pop est qu est ce que vous savez qui est
populaire humoriste un humoriste il a
fait son anniversaire et à 84 ans quand
il a fait son anniversaire hier il y
avait qui l'avait dj snake madame sans
gêne il avait tout le monde alors
regardez le popeck il a 84 ans et vous
allez voir c'est une petite rigolote
parce que ils connaissent pas trop
popeck sur idf1 on a popeck aouita
génération je voulais pas d'anniversaire
pompey qu'emilie pas décédée c'est vrai
bagis mais je sais pas je n'ai pas vu
des cierges et fait attention
non est-ce qu'on peut vérifier s'il vous
plaît en régissent puis j'ai fait
vachement attention cette année 1
voilà c'est ça sa mort cocopaq et bien
vivant leur bracelet après que sa
famille d'accueil 84 en soit c'est pas
il n'a pas de 202 nom et l'autre c'est
magnifique non il est mais je vais pas
mourir mais non n'a pas changé il n'a
pas changé vous savez j'ai reçus m'ont
donné de réponse à un sketch du web et à
baba plé vous ce soit pour à côté de moi
j'ai un truc que j'adore ma forme et je
regarde souvent c'est nous avec nos amis
de chez nous avec servier déjà bien
entendu le patron que j'embrasse ya eu
un reportage sur la plage et les jambes
bronzées
mais vu le retour plateau je crois que
le journaliste il pensait qu'à une chose
c'est m
voilà si on regarde le gouvernement
redoute l'arrivée en nombre de touristes
sur les plages
alors pour la séance de bronzage au
soleil sur le sable
il faudra attendre encore un peu mais ça
fait envie quand même passer ça c'est
ton bas le quartier ou halak a il était
il était chaud touba à thomas il était
chaud là tu te tiens tu me diras c'était
comme comment ça s'est passé
je voulais vous parler de michel
boujenah peut-être que tout le monde ne
le sait pas mais il a été guéri du
courant navires us dernièrement et sur
ses news il a justement évoquer cette
période délicate
il a notamment évoqué sa mère qui à plus
de 95 ans regardez ça fait partie des
images du jour c'est michel boujenah
regarder est ce que dans votre vie vous
aviez été aussi fatigué que vous l'avez
été durant cette période là par exemple
vous savez la personne la plus
incroyable que moi j'ai vu autour de moi
c'est ma mère 95 ans et demi elle a eu
le taux de co vide elle est parti en
ambulance avec le samu elle m'a regardé
elle me fait il m'aura pas il n'a pas eu
elle s'en est sortie elle a gagné une
bataille incroyable pour moi un qui
prouve que à 95 ans on peut gagner
trichet michel boujenah qui sera de
retour dans la grosse rigolade avant la
rentrée or il est exceptionnel
bichonnage suis sûr que vous aussi vous
pouvez re découvert ou découvert michel
aulas maxime même mois michel boujenah
je le connais c'est à travers les
bêtisiers et notamment au téléthon il ya
des fous rires voir les normes ne
s'arrête pas et la gelée redécouvert
grâce à cette émission ne savais pas à
quel point il était drôle et même
pendant pendant ce confinement il
faisait déposséder choses un peu sur
instagram
il est très drôle et on l'a vraiment à
découvrir dans la grosse rigolade il est
exceptionnel soit il nous a et c'est lui
qui a eu l'idée déjà soumis dans parce
que il était venu dans ces messieurs les
fais plein de bach et si on va faire une
émission comme ça oui jean michel
nouaille à bouche de trouver un gars je
suis désolé si battant mais je trouvais
regarde je trouve qu'il n'avait pas
beaucoup évolué dans sa façon de faire
lui mûri en fait qu elles sont fiables à
zebra carré moi vous avez enfin je l' ai
redécouvert jerry couvert et maintenant
je le kiffe à nouveau à c'est vrai je
suis très content qu'il soit revenu
parce que maintenant j'ai une très bonne
image alors qu'avant j'ai pour moi ce
n'est en fait parce que vous n'aviez pas
été voir ses nouveaux spectacles qu'ils
ont avec les films ya trois ans un
couffin il ya moi je me suis aperçu des
vielles goliath j'adorais ces films là
j'ai l'air
la promo qui l'a fait avec belmondo et
coluche moi il a toujours été drôle et
il a été un des comédiens aussi c'est
pâques un mec qui monte sur scène non
bien sûr on va merci ça lui va bien
d'avoir maigri ah ouais merci bas vous
vous faites le point vous êtes direct et
syna cet accord nous l'a toujours aimée
il vous adore vous adore franchement il
m'a parlé de la dernière fois qu'un
joueur c'est vrai jeu d'isabelle
morini-bosc 10 gige déjà vu ses mac
c'est mon style de meuf
c'est votre style michel boujenah moi
j'ai toujours adoré ce mec tutoyer
sortie région moi j'ai pas de style
physique un mba à faire plaisir à
locqueltas très bel homme oui très bel
hommage
oui oui kelly moi j'adore les gens
honnêtes et francs et là il a l'air de
ba de se dévoiler et j'adore ça parce
que ça se voit qu'ils qui dit ce qu'il
pense et je le sens bien je serai non
mais c'est vrai qu'on adore les gens
honnêtes et front c'est comme dans la
vie
mais bien sûr que c'est important au
regard des maximes il est honnête il est
front se serrent voilà et c'est pour ça
qu'on les aime également maire de lille
merci hier soir m6 a diffusé en prime
time un best-of des 25 meilleurs moments
de la france a un incroyable talent 2,4
millions téléspectateurs c'est pas si
mal je trouve un mauvais sommeil payer
parce que l'émission mérite est
nettement mieux l'homme c'est sur m6
c'est normal m6 adoré y avait un gars
qui s'appelait jeff il avait chanté un
petit poème vous rappelez pas ça en 2016
non pour aime à le revoir dans un
instant vous restez avec nous c'est sur
le plateau sur la tête de ma mère fait
au moins 56 alejo métallisé pas les
atouts du budget voté on perd tout de
suite chez rudy hier laver un best-of
d'incroyable talent pourquoi diable un
best-of je vous explique tout les chéris
en ce moment c'est vrai que les chaînes
font énormément d'économie et m6 j'ai
sont dit tiens on va refaire un best-of
d'incroyable talent parce qu'on a plein
de saison et on va voir voilà comment ça
se passe ça a plutôt bien marché de 4
millions de téléspectateurs pour une
émission qui a coûté 0
je peux vous dire c'est tout bénef pour
m6 hier soir ça c'est du bon pour eux
bien que tf1 qui dépense un peu d'argent
ce moment à perte
on sait pas pourquoi ils dépensent moins
d'argent et nous voilà on a voulu vous
mettre à prendre ou à laisser une
occasion pour terminer un an lorsque fut
là le prix d'émission on en dépense pas
mais après c'est le fallait mais on doit
laisser savez on a serré vraiment les
coûts je peux vous dire on a réussi à
sortir une émission qui est pour pour
l'émission je peux vous dire qu'on est
les plus compétitifs du paf
mais quand elle va gagner 250 milles
mais ben oui mais alors je sors ise pour
les plantes qui ont des havrais
bon ça on peut pas savoir voilà merci à
ces prêts bonnes interventions regardé
hier il y avait on a revu ce jeune homme
regardez dans le crabe le temps de
regarder quand votre vrai nom c'est quoi
c'est jeff d'accord je viens présenter
un poème boom bang
et si la vie était comme un boomerang
l'a dit nous prend la vie s'enfuit la
vie défilent à toute vitesse
à moi de l'attraper au bon moment
boomerang battu chercher au moins un
caramel tueur de la vie de sa vie j'ai
besoin de vivre sa bonne inspiration
boomerang
que vas tu cherchais boomerang a même
dessus de lui
j'ai besoin de connaître sa vérité
même si génial ouais j'adore les cotons
qui dit c'est génial will kelly bah moi
je pense que sur le plateau on a besoin
du jury parce qu'il ya du feeling c'est
une émission on a besoin d'avoir une
interaction avec le candidat mais là
avoir l'avis du jury à distance on se le
fait nous mêmes et je pense qu'on n'a
pas besoin donc les trucs les c'était
pour amener un petit truc en plus en
production je pense que ça ramène pas un
puits sans fond c'est à dire qu'ils ont
pris de la séquence la séquence complète
surtout quand elle était drôle mais là
c'est une casserole c'était le mec qui
était exactement passé un bêtisier pas
avoir la vie alors c'est vrai alors on a
aussi revu un candidat qui s'appelle
monsieur méthane lui sa spécificité
c'est de lâcher dégâts sur de la musique
classique 1 regardez je crois que c'est
lui qui inspire et la carrière de
benjamin castaldi
dans
moi
[Musique]
station debout
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que oui c'est donner une info
non allez jean michel à l'ailé on a vu
ils ont réactualisé en faisant parler le
jeu riche en annonces et moi et on voit
hélène ségara avec une mèche sur l'oeil
elle s'est pris un déversement sur les
réseaux sociaux quoi dont 20 cache-toi
mots jetés car il dit avec cette mèche
sur la wii
or en fait elle vient de subir pour une
grosse intervention sur l'oeil
donc c'était comme ça a été tourné yake
lot de regarder les c'était une façon de
démasquer sont inquiets qu'il ait qu'un
amour de femme
j'adore s'est embrassés c'est vraiment
dégueulasse les réseaux sont à la fois
que j'ai eue au téléphone elle m'a dit
le m envoyant il s'adresse à la fois
elle m'a dit j'ai franchement c'est un
acte grave touche et elle m'a dit cyril
ya trop de gens qui t'aiment
mais tu ne le vois pas regardez ce
qu'ils ne sortiraient pas indemnes de
cet amour avec toi moi j'aime pas casser
l'ambiance mais je sais que vous avez
vus à le faire non mais je trouve cette
séquence là elle est extrêmement
vulgaire émission familiale et je trouve
qu'il ya des je suis pas pour les
signalements c'est ça à mes choux qui
avaient des amendes qui était mais moins
mérité que cette séquence là qui pour
une fois des six mois quand tu regardes
ça qu'ils ont des casseroles non on va
regretter on refait la même sa
souffrance des gens pleins mais j'aurais
dit pareil c'est une casserole meilleur
il est passé quand on voit des mecs se
met des couteaux dans la bouche il ya le
plein de choses
les mecs qui tirent sur les dames qui
est sûre les roues et tout s'est passé
pas vulgaire ça c'est martin du lierre
mais c'est une performance de deux
circuits qui peuvent être fasse sous sa
cape farina ya rien à voir
sans sommation benjamin alard produit
sur le plateau on a doublé le fait pas
il dit à son fils roll à la regarde
il appelle tout bon ben voilà c'est
rigolo mais tout va bien de faire ça m'a
valu des demi-finales qui a récemment
répété en semaine au château ça m'a valu
une demi finale c'est pas si négatif
chez paou il a été long mais c'est vrai
que vous étiez vous petit beaucoup n'en
parlera pas de chez eux je veux dire non
mais calais jean pascal s'il est venu
c'est pour dénoncer c'est pas la peine
je veux dire on est là ici à l'étranger
en famille compte y est palpable
c'est qu'on est comme ce n'est pas le
diable et de sa vulgarité il fait le
tour du monde le mec là on en rigole on
rigole
il est payé une bil'in pour faire le
tour de monde et faire son numéro il
fait le tour du monde à péter à bt sahin
pétomane professionnelle la mémoire
alors moi je peux moi je peux comprendre
un peu de jambes je vous dis la vérité
jour me oui je te jette pas la pierre
mongin remis dans les mêmes security
croyable annonce on va avoir une pensée
pour bruno north la chaîne en 88 les
nuls il le faisait déjà avec misumi
ceinture
donc c'est un sketch donc incroyable
talent sur m6 les gants l hexagone
élégance les autres se taisent
allez les cherry dans les deux coups de
midi on a fait la rencontre d'un
candidat qui a un tatouage est à un
moment il à jean luc reichmann qui lui
demande sur quelle partie du corps il
l'a fait regardez bien sa réponse qui
est tatoué ici jean-paul toi t'as quoi
comme tatouage en un pelage et des
écritures lala sur le pied sur le cuir
tanné coin sur le piéger le chi ça
s'appelle c'est le sérénité opportunités
détermination chi oui le schiste ainsi
les changements des damiers sur le quai
alors oui il y en a plein gène
énormément moi je n'ai une quinzaine en
quinzaine de tatouages je suis déplacé
pour pas qu'on les voit passer ou
valérie voilée par une jolie peau c'est
dommage un bas bien sûr et elle a raison
elle travaille elle travaillait chez
estée lauder en artistique m'a mis une
très jolie peau c'est dommage que
j'allais faire un geek des têtes
je rappelle que c'est des métaux lourds
les tatouages c'est vrai tu sais que
j'ai voulu faire le visage et on m'a
retenu de le faire je le ferai pas mais
vous savez être consciente j'avais
failli vous faire tatouer le visage d'un
certain âge à tort j'adore les mais
votre visage est fan de crem estée
lauder ou les boîtes quoi clarins bâti
un petit papillon un petit truand sur le
visage
discret ouais ouais ouais j'aime
beaucoup moi je voulais faire une
merguez ici ça vous irait très bien
bah oui me france aussi franchement oui
et toi t'as pas de tatouage dans patate
one way et toi j'en ai sur le dos sur
l'épaule j'ai fait un ultime fois que
j'étais copé de pont et une sortie de
boîte j'étais complètement rincé le
tatoueur m'a dit cela profite à tous
quelqu'un qui dort super merci j'ai
envie en tout cas pour encore un bon
témoignage tenir et vos témoignages dans
cette émission m6 d'être là les yeux
regardez donc jean luc reichmann abordé
à ce candidat où il était tatoué
regarder
si je vous dis petit coup de folie
quasimodo d'état grand coup de folie je
me suis pour conquérir ma femme me suis
tatoué son prénom
lors de notre deuxième rencontre ah oui
et oui je ne regrette pas du tout ce
choix est ce que vous a fait de l'être
fait tatouer vous à paris dans le 10ème
non je parle je parle
voilà voilà voilà
non mais c'est comme ça vous allez dire
pour sa faire un tatouage moi je voulais
faire un cheval cabré à l'épaule à
l'époque quand j'avais 20 ans un cheval
cabré est le cheval avec le cabrer pas
du tout sauvage serait devenu un
hippopotame ça j'ai pas j'ai bien fait
les corps qui change la donne
le tatouage est tu fais tu feras là il
deviendra dès l'époque où ça qui est
beau nom mais non il y en a eu non parce
que justement majan sera la phase
suivante tout ça commence à fondre donc
non non j'en faisais partie avec mais si
vous avez une influence sur kiri ne la
laissez jamais faire un tatouage sur la
figure c'est s'être excusé quand on est
comme ça ça me travaille non mais
délicieux on a dit rekha ce chroniqueur
non mais c'est bon allez on va
maintenant parler d'une histoire
improbable
c'est en australie moi je suis souvent
bomb a bourlingué hors d'australie
je suis allé plusieurs fois de ce rallye
qu'est dû aller en australie c'est
vraiment du monde de rugby mais aussi
pour la coupe du monde de rugby le rugby
dans de rugby - avoir été une anecdotes
incroyables sydney il ya beaucoup plus
de leur ai demandé de la raconte et
analyse et voilà à sydney et des trucs
il ya beaucoup plus de femmes que
d'hommes ce que les hommes travaillent
souvent dans le bush à la compagnie
c'était avec les moutons et c'est très
admiratif sydney et du coup il ya
beaucoup de femmes et comment tu sors du
travail à 17 heures on va sur une plage
brugnac steira j'étais avec un pôle pour
la coupe du monde de rugby et on va un
bar et moi je commence à regarder les
filles dit surtout les regarde
ici tu regardes pas du bois ta bière tu
dis rien et voir les films vont venir
tout seul
or ça mais et après et une fille qui
arrive et qui n'est bon joueur commence
à parler en plus qu'on vienne paris x
tas et je me demande je suis numéro
combien j'ai des amis je suis la
première fille je viens de voir je
dirais oui et didier donfut numéro un je
dis oui elle est partie et c'est copé et
puis les coups deux heures après les
rebelles dit je suis toujours numéro 1
je dis oui elle m'a coupé allemand est
parti on a fait l'amour
non je vous jure mais deux appart là bas
ça se passe très très bien et c'était
vrai c'est vrai et sachez le bien doit
elle s'appelait scheer a tenu un petit
coucou les tabelles bordera coupe du
monde de rugby également bien regarder
cette histoire c'est un autre co duc
s'est introduit illégalement dans
l'australian amusé sommes en pleine nuit
moi j'adore les musées je fais des
musées pratiquement tous les week-ends
quand on n'était pas bien sûr un virus
et c'est vrai que j'adore les musées si
j'avais acquis fin de faire ce serait
également être un jour seuls dans un
musicien mais rêve absolu
regardez un australien a eu le culot et
l'idée complètement dingue de s'offrir
une visite privée dans un musée de
sydney regardez ces images il s'est
introduit en pleine nuit dans un des
plus grands musées de signer là en fait
il s'est même payé je pas le luxe plutôt
la grosse bêtise de faire des selphy
avec certaines pièces du musée vous
allez voir en bas c'est précisément la
gueule d'un tirano ce que vous imaginez
heureusement il a rien endommagé adriq
est tombé non mais il est très bon c'est
pas du câble a baissé bien la musique
graff est en ce moment alors qu'on est
en période confinement ça fait quand
même fils pck atelier vous si vous
deviez rester enfermé dans un endroit
comme ça introduire un endroit alors
introduire un arbre
[Rires]
c'est pour ça qu'en soit en australie et
donc à cause de la crise du corona les
c'est là où il ya les plus belles mina
d'opale dans le riyad en australie c'est
ça que tous les gens même ceux qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de faire des recherches
ils vont en australie pour un vin ceux
qui peuvent se déplacer pour rechercher
à de l'opal a fait comme l'organe tv rmc
chercheurs d'opale les ter précédent
c'est vrai vous avez regardé des coups
bas merci mes côtés ben voilà passé il y
avait un lieu qu'on pouvait introduire
de mylène nuit allez on vous l'a pas
écouté parc d'attractions
c'est quoi quoi de plus magique dans un
café réduit a personne tu fais les
attractions motors est magnifique merci
et vous et vous alors ben moi et je les
fais c'était le père lachaise tout seul
la nuit alors maintenant à mon âge j'ai
peur qu'il me garde contre les retombées
mais c'était thriller savoir ce qui se
passe est manquée serait en droit se
prépare alors outre les chats qui
sortent des tons parce que comme les
sols mouge des tombes s'enfonce et on va
des chats mais sortir de partout c'est
hallucinant et puis à des mecs qui vont
s'illustrer sur certaines tombes parfois
mais oui mais avant ça c'était méchant
et fermer la partie des gens qui
arrivent à s'introduire mes toilettes
illustré sous les traits il se frottait
sur les tombes quoi alors certaines
posséder sexuelle qu'un poète bien
poteau mais qu est ce qu on appelle à un
mourant quelqu'un qui est dessiné jusque
là giza gisant quelqu'un qui est dessiné
mais en vrai une statue cochon comme sa
mort comme mort et malheureusement le
sculpteur qui a fait de la statue d'un
poète anglais du 18e 19e
ils lui ont fait un sexe un peu
protubérants et du coup les femmes ont
pris ça pour une sorte de dôme à la
halle à la virginité balaa le fait
d'avoir des enfants
donc les vagues de fébrilité donc les
femmes qui n'avaient pas vont avoir des
enfants devront la nuit et se frotte le
sexe contre cette stature espère avoir
des enfants
il devrait vous avez essayé de remplacer
la statue asseoir et du coup la statue
tout rouillé sauf cesc et où le vison
non c'est tout contrat de photos au père
lachaise ils ont dû protéger la tombe de
jim morrison le rockeur parce qu'il ya
des gens qui faisaient l'amour sur sa
tombe
jim morrison et privés des rites
sataniques sur la tombe d'un match joué
la montre une vidéo qu'a fait beaucoup
réagir
l'autre l'entreprise over a fait un gros
bad buzz qu'a région annoncée lors d'une
visioconférence le licenciement de 3500
personnes ont regardé cette vidéo il
était 3700 dans le monde entier avoir
reçu une invitation par visioconférence
zoom de la part de leur entreprise
aujourd'hui sera votre dernier jour de
travail pour hubert en trois minutes
cette femme la directrice du département
clientèle du beurre leur annonce qu'ils
sont tous licencié sur le champ
la mesure concerne des employés
administratifs pas des chauffeurs
je sais que c'est extrêmement dur à
entendre
personne ne veut être dans un appel
vidéo comme ça qu'est ce t'en penses toi
jean pascal on pensait que ça ça devrait
passer un petit peu plus en france des
vidéos comme ça parce qu'elle a beaucoup
entre guillemets qui se plaignent de la
situation actuelle et on a un
gouvernement quand même qu'ils nous
aident financièrement et je pense qu'il
est très important d'être français
aujourd'hui dans trier mais plutôt
qu'américains parce que là ils sont sur
la paille et les mecs et nous on est
aidé donc à beaucoup ça gueule ça râle
mais je crois qu'il faut aussi
relativiser et regarder un peu plus loin
que le bout de son nez voilà c'est mon
coup de gueule ged jean-michel non non
je trouve que jean pascal a raison la
crs est terrible c'est un peu la méthode
américaine
aux etats unis c'est au printemps la
france un peu fait ça malheureusement c
est qu aux états unis vous n'êtes pas du
régent dans deux mois tu es parti non tu
arrives tu me prends des tu sors tu as
un vigile temps et écarts tonte est tout
de suite dehors une pub pour pas que ça
contamine les autres disant ouais c'est
des connards ils viennent de me dire et
c'est vrai que l'état de la méthode de
de trés trés terrible j'étais quand même
très ému quand même de le dire c'est pas
un succès c'est parce bord des larmes
quand même ils ont perdu 80 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires 2010 à 80 % du stock
car ils n'ont pas d'autre me wade comme
silent 80 sont les chiffres
ils n'ont pas d'autre solution que de
licencier malheureusement et je pense
qu'elle était ému quand j'ai mon chéri
non je disais c'est vrai que c'est un
drame 3800 personnes et c'est partout
dans le monde donc ils l'ont fait en
vision conférence c'est triste au régent
30 millions de chômeurs pour dire à
rebondir sur jean pascal aux étages et
ses 30 millions a dit salut ya pas de
chômage il n'y a pas de 84% etc
mais c'est l'ubs et risation aussi ils
ont fait de cette société lui berck et
40 mais aussi des gens au chômage
libéralisation c'est çà et là ils se
sont fait virer en numérisation quand tu
regardes ses se sont fait virer sur un
téléphone bah c'est en fait là c'est le
serpent qui se mord la queue et puis
sont partout dans le monde donc ça n'est
pas faire une réunion de 3800 personnes
confinées quelqu'un passe donc tu les a
virés par téléphone jeudi avec ses
employés par téléphone implication fait
virer par téléphone et j'ai envie de
dire la boucle est bouclée
jean vidal à thème dans mais si sûr
excuses moi excuse moi tu sais qu'on
fait les missions de nos amis suisses
étaient en train de dire que toulouse
est une ville sinistrée avec airbus qui
a perdu avec un pirate ou d'embrasser
sous les averses et sa région je sais
pas si j'ai envie de parler on va
terminer avec la vidéo du jour on l'a vu
de rappels d'urgence il y avait un
numéro qui était diffusé hier soir sur
tf6 et j'adore mois que là dedans appels
d'urgence aujourd'hui entre sourds on
est tombé sur un homme qui s'est fait
arrêter par les gendarmes il a un seul
objectif les rendre complètement ouf
regarder ça
l'individu ne s'est pas calmé pour
autant pas sur lui mais il ne cesse de
provoquer les gendarmes
allez c'est bon d'être arrête toi te
calmer de suite d'accord tu vas te
calmer de suite d'accord
bastien aux caisses et garde son sang
froid
non c'est quelqu'un qui a notamment vu
et qui cherche la provocation
histoire de nous mettre en porte-à-faux
une fois de plus tu vas te détendre tout
de suite je suis qu aucun exemple alors
tu vous tuera se calment et c'est
pataquès
vous êtes déjà fait arrêtez vous au
maximum je n'ai pas le permis donc je me
suis jamais fait même dans la rue conrad
n'ont jamais non nous avions déjà des
problèmes avec la maréchaussée l'air
aucun aucun regret juste peur de me
faire arrêter avec mon attestation
lorsque j'étais en tenant à une été
comme ça le faire parce qu'on peut
paraître deux personnes dans la voiture
non il ya des gens qui se faisait oui
gagner vous étiez vous avez des gt2 dans
la voiture ouais à droite
[Rires]